لقد وعدت أيضًا بمحاربة الفساد
والوقوف في وجه المسؤولين الفاسدين ،
لكنك فشلت في تسوية الأمور
خلال فترة احتجاجاتك المناهضة للحكومة
في صيف 2018 التي أنهت عرضك
لولاية ثانية ، سيدي ، هل تريد
فرصة أخرى في الوظيفة بشكل جيد لا  أعتقد حقًا أن الأمر
مختلف تمامًا في العام الماضي ، وأعتقد
أنه لم يكن لدينا هذا العدد الهائل من
الأشخاص الذين قُتلوا وأصيبوا ، وهو أمر
غير مبرر حقًا والأشياء
تسير على نحو خاطئ ، نحن أراكي نفخر بأنفسنا
مع الصحافة الحرة والمظاهرات الحرة
ولكن الآن الناس يُقتلون  الآن
حرية الصحافة مع
تعرض الأقنعة للخطر ، حسنًا ، تسير الأمور
في الاتجاه الخاطئ أو في
الاتجاه الصحيح ،
يجب علينا إصلاحها
بسرعة كبيرة ، لذا فأنت تقول إن الأمور
أسوأ بكثير مما كانت عليه العام الماضي
ولكن  لكن لماذا بعد 16 عامًا
من الحرب في العراق ونهاية صدام
حسين ، لماذا لا تستطيع إحدى دول
العالم الغنية بالنفط غير القادرة
على دفع الرواتب أن توفر
المتعة؟  لا يمكن لنظام الكهرباء
توفير مياه صالحة للشرب ربما
ساءت الأمور لكنها كانت سيئة للغاية
العام الماضي ، كذلك هل تعتقد حقًا
أن تغيير الحرس يمكن أن يحل
هذه المشاكل الأساسية وأنا أسألك
مرة أخرى هل تريد ولاية أخرى
كرئيس وزراء العراق  هل تعتقد حقًا أنه
يمكنك حل هذه المشكلات جيدًا ، أعتقد أني
أنظر ، أعني أنه كان هناك الكثير
من المشاكل في الماضي أتفق مع
هذا ولكن الإصلاحات تستغرق وقتًا
ولا تنسى خلال فترة ولايتي
لسنوات  لقد كنا نحارب منظمة إرهابية خطيرة للغاية ،
لقد
حررنا أرضنا في الأربعين من العمر وبدأنا
الإصلاح بدأنا في إعادة كل ما في
وسعنا لتقديم الخدمات للأشخاص الذين بدأناهم
للتو ، ثم
تحولت الأمور إلى مصطلح خاطئ وها نحن ذا  الآن في
العام الماضي لم تكن هناك حرب ، لدينا
الكثير من الموارد لأنه
لا تنسى خلال فترة ولايتي أن أسعار النفط
انخفضت لتتقاسم قيمتها مع
ما كانت عليه من قبل ، لذلك لدينا
مشكلة كبيرة  الآن هذه المشكلة ليست
موجودة ، لم أرغب في خوض حرب ، كل
الأزمات أعلى بكثير مما كانت عليه من قبل ،
لكننا بالتالي أسوأ حالًا مما كنا عليه من
قبل.